hey what's up guys mkbhd here back with
another high definition video today
we're going to be taking a look at
google chrome 9. we're going to be
teaching you how to enable google
instant in the omnibar up at the top of
chrome 9. this is something that
actually isn't that difficult to do but
it's something that i actually think is
a really cool feature and i'm glad
google decided to implement it so just
refresh your memory on google chrome 9
and actually in just google instant when
you start typing basically t-e-s-t
basically live loads results for you
before you even hit the enter button so
um
that's basically what we're going to be
seeing in google chrome 9 and the
omnibar first of all i'll try to include
a working link in the description for
chrome 9's download from the google
servers themselves but that's a lot
easier said than done as that link seems
to be constantly changing as this is
being updated a lot but once you're sure
you've gotten it working you can check
by hitting that wrench up at the top
right hand side and going to about
google chrome and once you've restarted
you should have chrome 9.0 dot something
so this is the latest version of google
chrome you can see it's a developer
build so now once you have that latest
version it's not enabled by default so
you go back up here to this wrench and
go to the options button stay under the
basics tab and down here under search
hit the enable instant button for uh
faster searching it'll give you a little
dialog box letting you know what exactly
it is and you can read this if you're
not sure exactly what it is go ahead and
hit ok hit close and if it doesn't work
first off go ahead and restart chrome
but i'll go ahead and try it t-e-s-t
and there you go chrome instant is
already working on the omnibar google
instant i really think it's a cool
feature uh that
i'm really glad they included this in
the first place just a quick little
video to show you guys uh keeping you up
to date with screencasts and uh one of
my favorite companies google so thanks
for this look at the hd tutorial of how
to enable google instant in chrome
version 9 developer build and i'll talk
to you guys in the next video
peace